- Do your kids like when you
do the Olaf voice though?
- They hate it.
They hate it because the Olaf voice,
that this is the voice right?
So, I tried for a while
reading them "Frozen" books,
and I thought it was so cool,
even though I do a horrible
Anna and Elsa.
But, they were just over it.
They didn't want it anymore,
so I started reading
the "Harry Potter" books at their school.
So every Friday, I go in.
- You do?
- I read all of book one
last year to the kids.
I read all of book two, but spoiler alert,
guess which two children
refused to come to the readings?
- [Kelly] It's 'cause you're the dad,
yeah.
- Right here.
So I will be sitting in front
of like a group of 40 children
all their friends, and
they'll like walk in
with their book bags and
be like "Hey dad, you good?
"All right, we're just
gonna go play back there."
I'm like, this was for bonding.
- This was for bonding where are you?
- I'm not getting paid for this.
- But that's gotta be amazing for them.
That would be amazing.
- It would, you would think.
- No, I mean the other kids as well.
To have you come and do
that, that's amazing!
- Oh, it's great.
And they pay me under the
table, so it makes it all worth.
Those kids pay me under the table.
- In like Skittles.
- No, hard cash.
- Hard cash.
- And I'll take your lunch money.